very warm welcome to you mr. Rosenberger
thank you for your time on Sky News
first of all your reaction to this
preliminary ruling were you expecting it
I don't think that anyone D anybody who
wanted to stick their neck out but it's
important to understand that this is
only a preliminary skirmish in this case
what the judge said is that sections of
the legal arguments which he had struck
out did not go to the heart of the case
in other words they didn't relate to
that letter you just referred to the
letter the Duchess sent to her father in
August 2018 yes I mean it is just the
the first step isn't it
and do you think they're right about
that do you think that what she was
trying to claim there was not central to
the core of her case that's certainly
the judges view and that was the view of
the newspapers what this was about was
the the legal arguments which put in
writing before a case comes to court it
doesn't just come out of nowhere you
have to set out the arguments on each
side so that the defendant knows what it
has to deal with in this case the
newspaper and the claimant has to put
her case the Duchess has put her case
clearly and associated newspapers
objected to three aspects of the
Duchess's case the allegation that the
newspaper acted dishonestly the
allegation that it had deliberately dug
up or stirred up conflict between the
Duchess and her father and the
allegation that it had an agenda of
publishing intrusive or offensive
stories about her and what the judge
said agreeing with the newspaper was
that these categories should be struck
out from the arguments now they won't be
part of the fool here when that takes
place I suppose it probably won't be
until next year
so what we're left with then is really
that the core of the case which is
really over privacy and interested in in
your view I mean did she have a
reasonable expectation to privacy around
that letter and I've read in your
article it gets complicated by the fact
that she apparently had put up friends
talk to another celebrity publication
and to make reference to that letter
that's exactly what the Mail on Sunday
is saying they say that the existence of
the letter was put into the public
domain
by an article in an American celebrity
magazine which quoted from friends of
the Duchess now she has said no she
didn't ask her friends to talk to this
publication after all that's obviously
what's going to be disputed the defense
say that the letter wasn't private or
confidential and they say that it's in
the public interest that it should be
made clear after all she was certainly
at the time a working member of the
royal family she's supported by public
funds and and the public needed to know
this her lawyers say that this letter is
quite obviously confidential it's a
private letter to her father and that it
really deals with her private life and
the sole purpose of publishing it was to
satisfy a curiosity among the newspapers
readers about her private life
publishing it wasn't in the public
interest
now that's those are the core issues and
whilst it's mostly a setback for the
Duchess that she's lost associated
newspapers are seeking 50,000 pounds
costs for the hearing last week and
she'll have to pay her own costs but the
the main point of the case goes on and
she does have the opportunity to put her
case in a bit more detail as she chooses
to but the more these preliminary
skirmishes go on them all the costs of
the case go up yes indeed it comes back
doesn't it - that old Gordian knot that
legal Gordian knot about you know
weighing up the right to privacy with of
course freedom of expression and that's
really an area where where law is very
much still developing isn't it so this
could be a very seminal case I think so
I mean we go back to the case that Naomi
Campbell brought against a newspaper
fifteen years ago now more and that was
a case that really set the modern law of
privacy and it's developing since then I
don't think that journalists always
quite understand the importance of
privacy it is something that we've
really only seen
the past 20 years or so journalists are
very familiar with libel you can't tell
lies about people you have to prove what
you say about people is true but privacy
is a developing area of the law and I
think this case will contribute to it
there was a case at which she the
Duchess relies on in which her
father-in-law sued the same newspaper
after published extracts from private
journals that Prince Charles wrote about
his visit to uncommon other places and
the male lost there on the other hand
this may be different so these these
issues are still very much to play for
and I think neither side is looking like
it's willing to back down and you're
saying there that we're likely to hear
the rest of this play out probably next
year could we see the Duchess in the
witness box I think we could I think she
will have to go into the witness box and
have to be cross-examined whether her
father though will have to give evidence
on behalf of the mail on Sunday is quite
another matter I think they probably
would want him to be there so that they
can discuss with him the arrangements
that they may have made with him or not
whether he agreed to let them have the
letter whether he agreed to let them
copy the letter in part or in full and
so that's why you know the case has been
described by some newspapers as Markel
against mark now we don't know if that's
going to happen but he does look as if
the Duchess is going to have to go to
the witness box it does look as if she's
going to be cross-examined whether
whether that's really worthwhile in the
sense that it reminds people of
something that they might otherwise have
forgotten about well we'll see if she
wins maybe she'll feel he was justified
if not it's really breaking up something
that as I saying many people have behind
them okay really good to get your
analysis there Joshua Rosenberg thank
you very much for your time on Sky News
and you win the bookshelf competition
very impressive
[Laughter]